This is the OMM lab
number 11 for week
13, Lumbar Diagnosis
and Lumbar Soft
Tissue Techniques.
I'm Dr. Jamie Mancini.
The objectives
for this lab are
going to be to
identify the
vertebral segments
T12 through S1,
evaluate the
connective tissue and
neuromusculoskeletal
system for
TART changes and
diagnosing type 1
and type 2 somatic
dysfunctions.
Also documenting those
somatic dysfunctions.
Be able to identify
evaluate and
understand the
physiology of the muscles
and tendons of the
back abdomen and
buttocks and hip
flexors and extensors.
Understand the importance
of the osteopathic
examination of
dysfunctions muscle tone
and function in the
clinical assessment of
back pain also assess
for contraindications
of soft tissue techniques
and demonstrate
the soft tissue
techniques of this lab
for the beginning of
your physical examination
you'll be looking
at the lumbar spine
region so visually
you'll start looking at
the posture see that
there is a lordotic
curve that's a backward
bending curve in the
lumbar spine um below
the thoracic spine
The T10 to T12 of
is also lordotic,
so you'll have to
be able to distinguish
between those.
While you're examining
visually, you might
want to have to sit
down in order to get
a better look at the
lower part of the
body to look for
symmetry. And you're going
to be looking at this
on the horizontal,
sagittal, and coronal
planes. and visually
you're going to
inspect left to right
of the plumb line
that's the midline and
comparing that to the
and to the horizontal
and coronal and
sagittal lines of the
room around you the sort
of a helpful reference
point so that you
can determine if the
different parts of
the body are level
from left to right and
from front to back.
Examples of
this are going
to include the
iliac crest.
That's a large
major indicator
of asymmetry if
the iliac crests
are already
looking on level.
Another part of the
examination is to
visually inspect
the range of motion
of the lumbar spine
and this is going
to be first with
active range of
motion testing.
Active is when the
patient is actively
using their muscles.
So this is a range
that the lumbar
spine or thoracolumbar
spine can
typically move in
in a healthy person.
When you are looking
at them side bending as
you're looking from
behind you're going to
want to take a look
at the actual line of
their spine to see if
the curve of side bending
to the right and to
the left is a smooth
curve or if there's sort
of like kinks in the
curve that may indicate
that there's somatic
dysfunction or a
restriction in movement.
You'll also be looking
at the muscle tone
as they move from side
bending and to side
and forward bending to
back and if those muscles
are symmetrical in
tone and activation.
In this table of
characteristics of vertebral
segmental dysfunction
and adaptations,
you'll see that for
non-neutral segmental
dysfunctions,
again these are the
Freyat's type 2 segmental
dysfunctions. The
documentation is based
on the biomechanical
position or preference
of the joint.
So the documentation
will have three
letters and then whether
it's left or right.
The first letter is
going to be whether
it's flexed or
extended. The second and
third letter are the
rotation and side
bending because in
type 2 dysfunctions
or non-neutral
segmental dysfunctions.
These are in the same
direction and then
you'll have the
sidedness left or right.
The opposite
of the somatic
dysfunction
preference or position
is the restricted
motion and the
restricted motion
is going to be
the opposite in
flexion extension
and the opposite
in left or right.
Sometimes the type 2
dysfunctions are in the
middle or apex
of a type 1 group
curve or at the ends
of the group curves
and in these cases
you would want
to treat the type 2
dysfunction before
treating the type
1 dysfunction.
What you're going
to be doing for the
lumbar spinal
somatic dysfunction
diagnosis is using the
anatomical landmarks
to identify the
lumbar spine region.
You'll be using
a screening
approach to identify
the segments
you want to focus
on diagnosing.
You'll use your
landmarks, bony
landmarks, to
figure out at which
level you are,
L1 through L5.
And then you'll palpate
for the posterior
transverse
processes laterally
from the spinous
process in that area.
Using bony
landmarks to find
the lumbar spine
you're going to
start with either
the 12th rib
or the iliac
crest and PSIS.
If you start with
the 12th rib you go
to the bottom of
the rib cage find
the 12th rib and
T12 spinous process.
The spinous process
just below that is
L1 and then it
continues down to L5.
The iliac crest height
are between L4 and
L5 and the PSIS's are
at the level of S2.
If you feel the top
of the sacrum it feels
like a flatter surface
and that's we're
going to be feeling
the sacral sulci. Just
above that there's a
little bit of space
before you get to the
L5 bony processes.
Once you've identified
the lumbar spine
area you're going to
see if any of these
spinous processes are
tender and you can start
evaluating for
paraspinal tart changes.
So as you move your
hands to the side you're
going to be looking
for signs of tart
changes, tissue texture
change, asymmetry, so
you'll find the transverse
processes and feel
if they're asymmetrical
as far as the depth
that they feel and
also for restricted
motion, which we'll go
over in a few slides.
And you're going
to be asking your
patient if any of
those areas are tender.
If there's any
tenderness to the actual
spinous process in
the middle, then you'd
want to see if there
was a history of
trauma or any signs
of trauma in the area.
If the paraspinal
musculature around
the transverse
processes is tender,
that's going to be
a sign that there's
likely a somatic
dysfunction there.
In the soft tissue
surrounding the
spine, this is primarily
your paraspinal
muscles and the
fascia, you're going
to be checking for
those tart changes,
tissue texture changes
you're going to
be looking for areas of
hyper or hypotonicity
so hypertonicity
being a muscle
that's contracted and
hypotonicity is going
to be one that is
more pliable supple
or not contracting
would be hypo very
hypotonicity again
areas of tenderness you
can look for color
changes because the
sympathetic chain
ganglia extend inferiorly
to L2. So you can
slide your fingers down
the spine and determine
if there is any
chronic or acute changes
from the sympathetic
chain ganglia
reflexes in that area.
And also continue to
check your
bony landmarks.
Checking your bony
landmarks includes feeling
the whole shape of
the bone so that you
can tell if you're on
the same part of the
bone from left to
right in finding the
lumbar spine transverse
processes you're going
to palpate about 1.5
inches lateral from
midline so from your
spinous processes
it's going to be about
one and a half to two
of the lengths of the
last bone or part of
your thumb the The
rotational segmental
motion examination is
going to involve putting
your thumbs symmetrically
on the transverse
processes of the
same lumbar segment.
Please confirm
that it's the
same lumbar
segment that your
thumbs are on from
left to right.
For a class, your
patient's going to be
prone. If you're in
the office and your
patient is uncomfortable
sitting, I mean
laying prone, or you
don't have a table for
that, you can do it in
the seated position.
But for class, we're
going to start out
with the patient
prone, and you're going
to be having your
thumbs on the transverse
processes of the
segment to be tested.
You're going to apply a
firm pressure anteriorly
in the patient's
body toward the table
on one side at a
time and be feeling
on the other
side if the other
transverse process
moves back or not.
If there's resistance
to that motion,
that means there's a
posterior transverse
process on the side
that resists going
anteriorly or
rotating to the left.
That means the
dysfunction is rotated to
the right if the right
transverse process
resists going anterior
with your pressure or
rotating to the left,
that vertebra. Once
you find your transverse
processes of the
lumbar spine, you can
check for side bending
and rotation. So to
check for side bending,
you have both
of your thumbs
on the transverse
processes.
You'll induce some
right side bending by
pushing the transverse
process to the left,
and you would check
for left side bending
dysfunction by pressing
the transverse process
towards the right,
the left transverse
process towards the
right that is. If there's
a restriction then
there's a restriction in
side bending and you
would name it for the
direction that it side
spends two without
restriction or with less
restriction. To check
for rotation you'll
again have your thumbs
on the transverse
processes. You'll push
the one transverse
process anteriorly while
monitoring the other
transverse process gently
with your other thumb.
If it goes anteriorly
on the right and the
left post, the left
transverse process
feels like it comes
posterior, then you're
rotating it to the left.
If you go to try to
rotate it to the right
by pressing anteriorly
with on the left
transverse process, but
the right doesn't come
back towards you into
your thumb, then it's
a left rotation
dysfunction because it
will rotate to the left
but not to the right.
Remember that the
motion of the vertebral
unit is guided by the
contours of shapes
of the guiding
surfaces of the facets.
So flexion and extension
is on the sagittal
plane, rotation is on
the horizontal plane,
and side bending is
on the coronal plane.
Because of the motion
guiding structures,
in type 2 dysfunctions,
rotation and
side bending are in
the same direction.
While the bony
structures, mostly
the facets,
guide the motion
in only specific
directions,
the connective tissue,
including ligaments
and tendons, limit
the range of motion.
When there's a severe
somatic dysfunction,
sometimes the connective
tissue may have
some tears, which may
make it hypermobile.
This is something
you should also
pay attention to
during your care.
Also, if there's
complaints of numbness,
tingling, pins
and needles, or
weakness, you'd want
to check for the
integrity of the
neural structures.
There are more
than one approaches
to diagnosing
extension versus
deflection in the
somatic dysfunctions.
With your thumbs
on both transverse
processes of the
same lumbar vertebra,
you can roll your
thumbs up over
the top of the
transverse processes.
And if the posterior
transverse process
becomes more symmetrical
with the other
side, then it's a
flexion dysfunction.
If you go the opposite
direction with
your thumbs and
that makes the
transverse processes
more symmetrical,
then that would be an
extension dysfunction.
Also, you can do
that in the full body
poses that we'll show
in the next slides.
If you're having trouble
finding the extension
or flexion component
of your synaptic
dysfunction with just
rolling your thumbs
up or down over the
transverse processes,
you can also palpate
for symmetrical
ease of rotation in
extension in the prone
position. You just
ask your patient
if they could prop
themselves up on their
elbows and rest
their face on their
hands like they're
watching TV and this
puts the lumbar
spine into extension.
If the transverse
processes have a
symmetrical ease
of rotation, also
considered to have no
posterior transverse
process, then that
would mean that
it's an extension
dysfunction because
it's more symmetrical
in extension.
The TV watching
pose is also similar
to the sphinx
pose and yoga
which is also
useful for checking
for lumbar extension
dysfunctions.
The flexion dysfunctions
can be assessed
in child's pose. You
ask your patient to
go onto their knees
and bring their hips
back into child's
pose and from there
you'll palpate the
transverse processes,
assess rotational
component from one
side to the other to
determine if they're
more symmetrical
in rotation and
flexion to make it a
flexion dysfunction.
As you document
the somatic
dysfunctions you
find on your patient,
you'll write them
down again as flexion
or extension, rotated
and side bent to the
same side. So the
side that has the
transverse process
that's posterior is going
to be the side that
it's rotated towards.
So if you find a
posterior transverse
process on the right
side of L4, and
when you roll your
fingers up over
the transverse
processes, that posterior
transverse process
disappears because
it's more symmetrical
in flexion.
I'm sorry, L3. Then
this would be a
L3 flexed, rotated,
and side bent to
the right. And that
is the description
biomechanically of
its motion on L4.
This is a list of
the abbreviations
for documenting somatic
dysfunctions on
the physical exam.
This chart summarizes
the biomechanical
motions of somatic
dysfunctions
that you'd find
on physical exam.
After locating and
documenting type 1
sematic dysfunctions,
you'll move on to
type 1 dysfunctions.
So these are going
to follow Freyette's
first principle.
And in the type
1 dysfunctions,
again, these are
group curves.
It's considered neutral,
so there's no change
in flexion or extension
and the rotation
and side bending are
in opposite directions.
Sometimes this is
formed as a compensation
to other health issues
or misalignments.
On the physical exam
in the presence of
a type 1 somatic
dysfunctions all of the
transverse processes
of that group
dysfunction will be
posterior on the same
side so if the vertebral
segments have a
transverse process
as posterior from L1
to L4 then you're
gonna have a neutral
side bent right rotated
left dysfunction.
As you motion test
inflection and
extension there
should be no change
in the posterior
transverse processes
that's what
makes it neutral.
Your diagnosis would
be notated as L1 to
L4 neutral side bent
right rotated left and
the abbreviation is
below there and SRRL.
The neutral or type
1 dysfunctions have
groups of three or more
segments, and these
segments may include
the thoracic spine.
This picture
represents a neutral side
bent right, rotated left.
Keep in mind that
the motion of a
vertebra in any one
plane of motion will
influence the
motion of that same
vertebra in any other
plane of motion.
This is a pictorial
representation
of a type 2 dysfunction,
so single segment.
In the lumbar sacral
spring test, the
patient lies prone on
the examination table.
The physician stands
to the side with the
dominant eye over the
midline. You place
one hand over the
midline of the lumbar
region with the thenar
eminence over the
lumbar sacral junction.
The lumbosacral
junction is L5 and the
base of the sacrum.
The fingers extend
superiorly over the
spinous processes and
paravertebral tissue.
You provide a short
quick push into the
anterior direction
of the body and
that's a few millimeters
or so of a push.
This will evaluate
for springiness
or compliance of
the lumbar spine
or you'll feel
resistance or
stiffness to the
springing motion.
The resistance is
considered a positive
test. If there's
compliance or springiness
to the spine then
it's a negative test.
Sometimes you'll
have a patient who
can't tolerate laying
prone, and you can
also perform the
physical exam of the
lumbar spine in a
seated position as
well as a lateral
recumbent position.
In this chart prepared
by Dr. Koyman,
you can see that
the rotation of a
somatic dysfunction
is on a vertical axis
in a horizontal
plane, side bending is
all around an AP axis
on a coronal plane,
and flexion extension
happen around
a transverse axis
on a sagittal plane.
This can be checked
in prone or lateral,
recumbent and or
the sphinx position.
In the rotation aspect
your thumbs are on
the transverse processes.
For side bending
you can have the thumbs
on the inferior facets
of the articular
columns and in flexion
extension you can also
put your finger pads
on the spinous processes
or between them.
And here you're
checking for the
ease of preference
and symmetry.
In this chart prepared
by Dr. Koyman,
you're looking at
active testing, looking
at neutral range
flexion and extension.
In the lumbar spine,
in neutral mechanics
or type 1 mechanics,
side bending and
rotation occur in
opposite sides and this
motion is guided by
the vertebral bodies.
In the non-neutral
or type 2, the side
bending rotation
on the same side
and it's governed
more by the facets.
A common mistake when
people are learning
documentation of
somaticus functions is to
document the direction
that is restricted in
motion. However, semi
dysfunctions are named
for the freedom of
motion or ease of motion.
You'll be practicing
the soft tissue
techniques and the
goals of these are to
relax muscles and fascia,
improve circulation
to the muscles that
can include arterial
blood and well as
well as venous and
lymphatic drainage,
improving mobility,
decreasing pain,
interfering with
regression of acute
pain to chronic pain,
to relax the stretch
reflexes, and an
overall improved
patient quality of life.
Although there
aren't any absolute
contraindications to soft
tissue techniques that
are especially noted,
there are cautions
and relative
contraindications for local
application of soft
tissue techniques. That
includes fractures,
open wounds, soft
tissue or bony infections
at the local site,
abscesses, DVTs,
coagulopathies,
neoplasms, or
directly over
the site of a
recent operation.
Here are the
links to the soft
tissue techniques
of this lab.
You're going to
be performing a
prone traction
using two hands.
This is going to involve
the patient laying
prone. First identify
the lumbar paraspinal
muscles and palpate
for any hypertonicity
in the myofascial
structures and then
perform the technique.
In the prone pressure
with counter leverage
technique, the patient's
laying prone with
their head torn head
turned towards you.
You'll be standing
on the opposite
side of the side
to be treated.
You place your thumb
and thenar eminence of
the cephalet hand on
the medial aspect of
the paravetebral muscles
and fascia that's
overlying the lumbar
transverse processes.
That's going to be on the
side that you
want treated.
Then you'll use
your caudate hand to
contact the ASIS
on the side to be
treated. Then you'll
gently lift that
ASIS towards the
ceiling, so upwards.
Use a gentle force
ventrally and
laterally with
the cephalate hand
perpendicular to the
grain of the fibers
of the perivertebral
musculature.
Hold that for several
seconds then slowly
release. Then you
repeat this these
last steps four through
six several times
in slow, rhythmic,
and kneading fashion.
Then you can reposition
your cephalodic
hand to contact different
levels of lumbar
spine that you find a
dysfunction or
tissue tension in.
This is the prone
pressure with counter
leverage technique
and with the hand
that's more cephalad
you're going to be
stabilizing the
torso and then with
your more caudid hand
you're going to be
bringing the
body towards you.
In the supine extension
technique, the
patient lines supine
while the physician
sits on the same
side to be treated.
Your palms will be up
under the patient's
lumbar spine, placed
with the finger pads
on the perivertebral
musculature between
the spinous and the
transverse processes.
apply a gentle
ventral lateral force
perpendicular to the
perivertebral muscular
grain fiber you're going
to create a fulcrum
by applying a downward
pressure through
the elbows on the table
so this way you're
making a teeter
-totter out of your
forearms let's say
your elbows go down and
your hands or fingers
go upward in order
to make the technique
less of a strain on
the physician.
This way you can
produce a lateral
stretch
perpendicular to the
thoracic perivertebral
or lumbar
perivertebral
musculature.
You'll hold it for
several seconds and then
release to repeat
steps four through six
several times in a
gentle rhythmic and
kneading fashion and
then repeat the technique
at a different level
if there's more tissue
tension or dysfunction
in other levels.
This is the supine
extension soft tissue
technique in which
the patient is supine
and you'll be using
both of your hands
in the paraspinal
musculature to induce
a lateral stretch
it's perpendicular
to the spine until
you have a release.
Points to remember
are how to find the
anatomical landmarks
for the lumbar spine,
the tart changes,
and how to
diagnose type
1 and type 2
dysfunctions of
the lumbar spine.
Also to document the
somatic dysfunctions.
You'll want to
understand the importance
of the osteopathic
examination of
dysfunctions, muscle
tone, as well as function
in the clinical
assessment of back pain,
and know how to
demonstrate the techniques
for prone traction,
prone pressure with
counter leverage,
and supine extension.
Here are the references
from this presentation.
And here's the link
for lecture feedback.